monsieur le le président monsieur le
garde des saau monsieur le le rapporteur
mes chers collègues notre pays traverse
une crise démocratique au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle de
2022 l'abstention a atteint 28 % un
record depuis
1969 comme en 2017 plus d'un Français
sur deux ne s'est pas déplacé pour voter
aux élections législatives aux élections
régionales de 2021 ce sont deux Français
sur trois qui se sont désintéressés du
scrutin même les municipales de 2020 ont
connu pour la première fois de notre
histoire une abstention supérieur à 50
%. on a beaucoup disserté sur les causes
de ce désamour on le présente parfois
comme une fracture
démocratique qui affecte certaines
catégories d'électeurs et d'élect
les jeunes les plus précaires ou les non
diplômés on s'attache donc à chercher
des solutions ciblé pour combler cette
fracture mais la vérité c'est que cette
désaffection touche désormais toutes les
catégories de Françaises et de français
il y a quelques jours le politiste Rémi
Lefèvre signer une tribune dans l'OPS
pour s'alarmer que la que la politique
n'intéresse plus personne
ce désintérêt grandissant est renforcé
depuis 7 ans par une pratique du pouvoir
vertical
autoritaire brutal et solitaire qui le
transforme parfois en dégoût
47-1 442 443 493 les cou boutoir
constitutionnel qui ont rythmé les
débats autour d'une réforme des
retraites rejeté par 7 Fran
sur 10 ont poussé jusqu'à ses limites la
logique de la 5e République qui
concentre les pouvoir aux mains de
l'exécutif le déséquilibre de nos
institutions marqué par la faiblesse des
contrepouvoirs organique et un exécutif
quasi monarchique n'a eu de cesse de
saperer la confiance des Françaises et
des Français dans nos institutions et le
personnel
dans la dernière vague du baromètre de
la confiance politique 64 % de nos
compatriotes estime que la démocratie ne
fonctionne pas bien en France c'est 7
points de plus par rapport à 2022 et 12
points de plus en moyenne que nos
voisins européens c'est bien la pratique
actuelle du pouvoir doublant ce
déséquilibre institutionnel d'un mépris
pour le Parlement pour pour les corps
intermédiaires et pour la conscience
civique de nos compatriotes qui les
écœur
l'historien Patrick Boucheron le dit en
des termes définitifs je cite je n'ai
pas l'expérience d'un gouvernement qui
est à ce point mépriser les sciences
sociales
l'université l'exercice collectif de
l'intelligence ù le le mouvement social
tant de suffisance pourtant
d'insuffisance exercice collectif de
l'intelligence voilà ce que je souhaite
remettre à l'honneur par cette
proposition de loi
constitutionnelle alors qu'il n'aspire
qu'à participer davantage à la vie
démocratique de notre pays les Français
et les français se sentent désaisis du
processus de décision
publique la démocratie leur paraît
confisqué comme en atteste aussi la
colère et parfois la violence qui
s'exprime dans la rue à chaque nouveau
passage en force pour renouer ce lien de
confiance il est
indispensable de remettre les citoyennes
et citoyens au cœur du processus de
légitimité de la décision politique il
s'agit de passer d'une démocratie
gouvernée qui infantilise trop les
Françaises et les Français à une
démocratie gouvernante qui leur redonne
une voix au chapitre la modernité dans
une démocratie
se mesure au degré de participation des
citoyennes et citoyens et sur ce point
notre pays est très en retard il nous
faut inventer une démocratie moins
intermittente et plus continue pour
qu'entre chaque élection perdure la
contestation le dialogue la délibération
permanente entre les gouvernés et les
gouvernant c'est d'autant plus urgent
que la défiense de nos compatriotes
envers le gouvernement pourrait un jour
les pousser à confier nos institutions
déséquilibrées à des forces politiques
qui trouverait tous les moyens de faire
avancer un agenda
illibéral antisocial et
antidémocratique notre République a
besoin d'un nouveau souffle la culture
civique et les nouvelles solidarités
dont nous aurions besoin pour construire
une société apaisée et rassemblée
sont en contradiction radicale avec la
gestion paternaliste et la passivité
populaire que produit notre
Constitution convention citoyenne budget
participatif tirage au sort juris
citoyens droit de pétition consultation
locale droit d'initiative citoyenne les
Françaises et les Français doivent être
plus souvent associés aux décisions qui
les concernent c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il
réclame puisque 68 % d'entre eux pensent
que la démocratie fonctionnerait mieux
en France si les citoyens et citoyennes
étaient associés de manière directe à
toutes les grandes décisions politiques
de notre pays alors que nos concitoyens
et concitoyennes sont plus éclairés plus
informés que jamais l'heure est venu de
faire confiance au peuple et d'être
fidèle à l'article 3 de notre
Constitution
qui dispose en son premier alinéa que la
souveraineté nationale appartient au
peuple qu' l'exerce par ses
représentants et par la voix du
référendum c'est en parti pour répondre
à cette aspiration qu'à l'occasion de la
r révision constitutionnelle de 2008
nous avions introduit à l'article 11
alinéa 3 de notre Constitution un
référendum dit d'initiative partagée le
rip et pourtant presque 10 ans jour pour
jour après la promulgation des lois du 6
décembre 2013 portant application du
référendum d'initiative partagé aucun
RIP n'a pu être mise en œuvre aucune des
cinq propositions de RIP enregistrées
depuis
2019 n'a pu surmonter le parcours semé
d'embûche qui mène au référendum
185 signatures de parlementaires
4800000 signatures de citoyens et
citoyennes inscrits sur les listes
électorales les fourches codines du
Conseil constitutionnel a passé et la
bienveillance dans une ultime étape du
Parlement chacun s'accorde aujourd'hui à
dire que les concepteurs du Rip ont tout
fait pour qu'il soit
inapplicable je me réjouis d'ailleurs de
constater que le rapporteur admet que
les gardes-fous posés pour encadrer le
recours à la procédure du référendum
d'initiative partagée se sont révélé de
véritables hers juridiqu et qu'il
partage le constat de la nécessaire
clarification et de la simplification de
la procédure de référendum d'initiative
partagé l'ambition de ce texte n'est pas
plus grande que cela et sa méthode est
simple il s'appuie sur l'expérience de
ces 10 dernières années et sur la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
pour lever les verrouses qui empêchent
l'expression directe du peuple un léger
élargissement du champ d'application du
référendum un abaissement du seuil de
signature de parlementaire à 93 un
abaissement du seuil de signature
citoyenne à 1 million l'octroi de
l'initiative aux citoyens eux-mêmes
l'explication du vetau accordé au
Parlement pour empêcher la tenue du
référendum je sais bien qu'il est
difficile pour les parlementaires que
nous sommes de partager le peu de
pouvoir que nous accorde la constitution
de la 5e République mais il n'y a pas
d'opposition entre d'un côté le
référendum qui serait suspect par nature
et de l'autre le Parlement qui serait
irréprochable par nature les deux ont
des vertus et cette opposition si si
elle est idéologique en tout cas ne
correspond pas à l'esprit de la
Constitution ni dans son article 3 ni
dans son article 11 en démocratie le
peuple est souverain n'oublions jamais
que nous en sommes ici de modestes
représentantes et représentants à ce
titre notre rôle est de tout faire pour
faciliter son expression le prof de la
démocratie c'est qu'elle ne sait jamais
de s'approfondir sinon elle meurt n'ayez
pas peur faites confiance aux françaises
et aux Français et montrez-leur en
retour qu'ils peuvent à nouveau avoir
confiance dans les institutions de leur
République merci la parole est à présent
notre collè Philippe B rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour 10
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le garde
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois chers collègues je remercie
Monsieur chanterel et le groupe
socialiste de nous avoir donné
l'occasion d'un débat sur le référendum
d'initiative
partagé c'est un sujet qui fait l'objet
de de nombreux travaux certains autour
du président du Sénat
actuellement le président de la
République a lui-même annoncé des
initiatives à ce sujet et il n'est pas
anormal
8 ans après l'entrée en vigueur de la
création de ce dispositif par la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 grâce
à l'intervention d'une loi organique
d'essayer de faire une évaluation du
dispositif j'ai abordé cette
question je crois avec esprit
d'ouverture j'ai eu avec Monsieur
chanrel deux longs entretiens très
confiants qui nous ont permis d'aller au
fond des choses j'en ai tirer la
conclusion que le sujet était sans doute
trop important pour pouvoir être traité
de manière
approfondie dans le cadre de l'examen de
cette proposition de loi puisque le
temps qui nous est imparti est
évidemment très court et que
l'importance des amendement qui serait
nécessaire pour trouver un terrain
d'entente entre nous rend difficile de
venir au bout de la démarche dans le
cadre de l'examen de ce
texte il n'y a pas d'objection de
principe à étendre le champ du
référendum la Constitution a été
modifiée déjà en 1995 et en 2008 pour le
faire c'est un sujet de réflexion que
nous devons avoir entre nous et la vertu
du travail parlementaire c'est
précisément qu'il permet de rechercher
des terrains d'entente et de trouver une
conciliation entre des points de vues au
départ différents si j'ai estimé et et
la commission des lois a bien voulu s'en
convaincre que on ne pouvait pas aboutir
maintenant c'est en raison d'un certain
nombre de
problèmes technico juridico politiques
qui méritent d'être regarder à la
loupe
premièrement ce texte ne se borne pas à
traiter du référendum d'initiative
partagé il traite du référendum de
l'article 11 c'est-à-dire d'un pouvoir
présidentiel dispensé de contreein d'une
arme qui a été confiée par la
Constitution au président de la
République pour pouvoir sur des sujets
d'une importance capitale pour le pays
donner la parole aux Français afin que
leur décision soit
irrévocable la banalisation du
référendum est d'ailleurs
incompatible avec cet apport de la
Constitution de 1958 qui est en rupture
avec la tradition républicaine en
vigueur et qui a permis de
réaclimiter le
référendum à la pratique de notre
République puisque il en avait été
proscrit pendant en réalité près d'un
siècle à cause des abus auxquels il
avait donné lieu c'est tout de même
surprenant qu'on é logé à l'article 11
de la Constitution sur les pouvoirs
présidentiels dispensés de contrein
dans un régime dont on critique
volontiers la verticalité qui n'a cessé
de s'aggraver dans la période récente le
référendum
d'initiative partagé qui mériterait
d'être situé ailleurs que dans les
pouvoirs
présidentiels l'élargissement du champ
du référendum que vous proposez qui vise
à retirer le barrage que constitue
l'exigence que le référendum porte sur
une réforme
et qui vise aussi à faire en sorte que
les mesures fiscales puissent être
soumises au pays par référendum me
paraît mériter discussion
quand vous estimez que le texte de la
Constitution de 2008 a empêché de faire
des référendum qui auraient été utiles
pour les Français je porte le regard sur
les référendums qui ont été empêchés par
ce texte et je me dis au fond si on veut
donner vie au référendum d'initiative
partagé est-ce que c'est bon d'exposer
ce référendum
à un taux d'abstention considérable
contte tenu du peu d'intérêt que les
Français auraient pour la question qui
leur serait posée faut-il privatiser
Aéroport de Paris faut-il le maintenir
public vous posez la question au
français êtes-vous sûr que vous aurez
plus de 10 % ou 15 % participation la
banalisation du référendum dans le cadre
du référendum d'initiative partagé c'est
le meilleur moyen de tuer le référendum
d'initiative partagé et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai été très circonspect
à l'égard de votre proposition non
seulement parce que vous élargissez les
pouvoirs du Président de la République
en ce qui me concerne mais ça n'est
peut-être pas votre avis je trouve qu'il
en a déjà bien assez et en plus vous
risquez de tenir en échec une
disposition sur le référendum
d'initiative partagé qui est encore
toute jeune parce que si elle n'a pas
fonctionné pendant ces premières années
de vie ça n'est tout de même pas une
raison pour considérer que elle ne
fonctionnera jamais
imaginez que on doiv absolument
mobiliser 48 millions d'électeurs parce
qu' 1 million d'entre eux a décidé qu'un
sujet devait être soumis au vote des
Français c'est tout de même euh une
démarche qui me pose problème je
considère que
euh nous avons euh une grande prise de
risque pour l'instrument si nous
l'utilisons dans de telles conditions
d'autant plus que pour recueillir un
million de signatures il faut et il
suffit qu'un groupe de pression armé de
militants voire d'activistes se mobilise
donc faisons très attention mes chers
collègues à ce point
alors je laisse de côté l'aspect pouvoir
présidentiel dont je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il soit opportun de
l'étendre et je me prononce maintenant
sur les dispositions que vous avez voulu
introduire pour le référendum
d'initiative partagé je vous dis 1
million c'est sans doute pas assez vous
me dites
4850000 c'est trop on pas eu le temps de
discuter sur le bon chiffre on pourrait
certainement évoluer les uns et les
autres sur ce point et trouver un
compromis quant au nombre de
parlementaires il me semble qu'il n'a
jamais été un obstacle jusqu'à présent
je ne connais pas un seul cas où le
nombre de signatures de parlementair
nécessair pour déclencher la procédure
n'est pas été réunie il y a pas eu
d'échec causé par un nombre insuffisant
de signature parlementairire pourquoi
donc changer ce
nombre alors vous avez aussi voulu dans
un souci
d'exhaustivité créer une nouvelle
procédure une procédure inversée par
rapport à celle de 2008 on commencerait
par les signatures de citoyens et on
terminerait par les signatures de
parlementaires mes chers collègues je
vous dis que si on veut vérifier qu'un
telle une telle démarche serait conforme
à nos libertés fondamentales il faut
tout de même trouver un moment où un
examen de constitutionnalité pourra se
faire mais si se fait avant la seconde
signature on considérera que on donne
pas sa chance à la nouvelle procédure et
s'il se fait après avoir recueilli x
millions de signatures et que le Conseil
constitutionnel dit mais ça porte
gravement atteinte à la déclaration des
droits de l'homme on ne peut pas
organiser ce référendum à ce moment-là
ce sera très gênant par exemple pour le
Conseil constitutionnel de dire non vous
le mettrez dans l'embarras alors
naturellement c'est une institution très
noble et il peut surmonter cet embarras
mais tout de même veillons à ce que nos
institutions ne soient pas mis dans une
situation qui ferait d'elle un objet de
contestation alors enfin vous avez
proposé que le
référendum quand on a ra frranchi toutes
les étapes de la procédure soit
obligatoire
sauf dans le cas où le texte de la
proposition de loi serait
rejeté par le Parlement et vous avez
raison on va tout de même pas quand le
Parlement a
rejeté un texte de loi le soumettre au
français sinon ça mettrait le Parlement
en contradiction possible avec les
français ce qui est
évidemment un risque toxique pour la
démocratie représentat
mais vous n'avez pas envisagé le cas où
tout simplement après amendement le
Parlement
adopterait la proposition de loi
voulez-vous donc qu'un projet de loi
dont les citoyens auraient pris
l'initiative dans le cadre de cette
procédure qui serait adopté par le
Parlement puisse être rejeté ensuite par
le pays je crois que ce travail mérite
d'être achevé et c'est la raison pour
laquelle sans vous opposer une fin de
non recevoir la commission des lois n'a
pas approuver votre proposition et je
souhaite que nous puissions en
rediscuter ensemble dans les mois qui
viennent merci la parole est à présent
monsieur Éric Dupont moréti garde des
saau ministre de la
Justice monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le sénateur
chantrelle monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs la loi et l'expression de la
volonté
générale tous les citoyens ont le droit
de
concourir personnellement ou par leurs
représentants à sa formation c'est en
ces termes que l'article 6 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de
1789 à tranché ou plutôt ou plus
exactement surmonter le débat qui
opposait les partisans de la
souveraineté nationale à ceux de la
souveraineté populaire à l'époque deux
conceptions radicalement opposées de la
démocratie
s'affronter Rousseau affirmé que je le
cite toute loi que le peuple en personne
n'a pas ratifié et nul tandis que c
déclarait quant à lui en parfait
contre-point que je le cite le peuple ne
peut parler ne peut agir que par ses
représentant la constitution de 58 dont
nous venons de fêter le 65e anniversaire
a choisi une voix médiane son article 3
dispose en effet que la souveraineté
nationale appartient au peuple qui
l'exerce par ses représentants et par la
voix du référendum
mais c'est son article 11 qui précise
les conditions
d'utilisation du référendum cet article
permet en effet au président de la
République de soumettre au référendum
tout projet de loi portant sur
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics ou
la ratification d'un traité qui sans
être contraire à la Constitution aurait
des incidences sur le fonctionnement des
institutions la révision
constitutionnelle du 4 août
1995 a étendu ce champ référendaire au
projet de loi portant sur des réformes
relatives à la politique économique ou
sociale de la nation et au service
public qui concourt issu des travaux du
comité baladure la révision
constitutionnelle du 23 juillet 2008 a
quant à elle élargi ce champ
référendaire au question de politique
environnementale surtout elle a créé le
référendum d'initiative partagé ce
dispositif constitue au regard de notre
histoire politique une véritable audace
il a de manière inédite mise entre les
mains des citoyens un outil destiné à
les faire participer activement au
processus d'élaboration des lois cet
outil on l'a vu ces derniers mois a fait
naître de fortes attentes
mais aussi il faut le dire quelques
frustration 15 ans plus tard il est
temps de dresser un premier bilan de ce
référendum d'initiative partagé il
s'agite avant tout d'une innovation
majeure dans notre histoire
constitutionnelle l'expérience des
dernières années des pistes
d'amélioration du dispositif
apparaissait clairement en 2008 le
constituant avait de manière prudente
érigé de solide
gardefous destiné à empêcher que la
procédure du
référendum ne viennent remettre en cause
la stabilité de nos institutions ou
qu'elle ne soit dévoyée à des fins
démagogique plusieurs initiatives ont vu
le jour depuis l'entrée en vigueur de ce
dispositif ce qui démontre que tant les
citoyens que les parlementaires portent
un réel intérêt à cet outil de
respiration démocratique mais aucune de
ces initiatives n'a pu aboutir dès lors
certains se demandent légitimement si
les gardesfous dressés en 2008 ne
constituent pas en réalité des her
infranchissable la première question se
pose que pose cette proposition de loi
et celle essentielle du nombre de
soutiens citoyens et parlementaires
exigé pour que la procédure puisse être
enclenchée en 2008 le constituant a
retenu le seuil d'un 5è des membres du
Parlement et celui d'un diè des
électeurs inscrits sur les listes
électorales l'expérience a montré que si
le seuil d'un 5è des membres du
Parlement peut-être atteint il est
permis d'en douter s'agissant de celui
d'un diè des électeurs inscrit à ce jour
et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
rapporteur l'initiative la plus n'a pu
recueillir qu'un peu plus d'un million
de soutiens sur les
4,7 millions de soutiens requis la
deuxième question évidemment porte sur
le champ du référendum qui résulte du
premier alinéa de l'article 11 tel
qu'interprété par la jurisprudence du
Conseil
constitutionnel par certains aspects ce
champ mériterait sans doute d'être
clarifié il faut s'interroger aussi sur
l'article cculation entre l'initiative
citoyenne et le travail parlementaire la
possibilité conférée aux assemblées de
mettre un terme au processus
référendaire par l'examen de la
proposition de loi à soulev quelques
critiques pour certains le dispositif
mériterait d'être plus contraignant pour
le Parlement nous devons cependant être
très attentifs à ne pas déposséder le
Parlement de ses prérogatives à la fois
naturelles c'est légitime c'est donc sur
ces questions sur ce bilan mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qu'il nous faut
collectivement nous pencher et répondre
en somme à une question très simple le
dispositif est-il à la hauteur de
l'ambition que nous portons pour notre
démocratie du point de vue du
gouvernement le constat qu'appelle ce
bilan est clair le dispositif du
référendum d'initiative partagé mérite
d'être amélioré
en ce sens la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle de monsieur le
sénateur Chantrel propose des pistes qui
sont intéressantes d'abord l'abaissement
du seuil de soutien citoyen semble
nécessaire afin de rendre la procédure
plus
effective la nécessité d'abaisser le
seuil de soutien parlementaire est quant
à elle moins évidente la proposition de
loi retient que retient les seuils d'un
million de citoyens et d'un 5è des
membres du Parlement ça me semble être
une cible un peu ambitieuse mais permet
d'ouvrir la réflexion ensuite ouvrir la
possibilité d'une initiative citoyenne
soutenue par des parlementaires plutôt
que l'inverse est tout à fait
intéressant dès 2019 le gouvernement
avait proposé d'aller jusqu'au bout de
la démarche en proposant aux citoyens
d'initier eux-mêmes la
procédure je je suis à vrai dire
toutefois moins convaincu par d'autres
aspects de cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle tout d'abord
l'extension du champ du référendum à la
politique fiscale ne m'aparaît pas
souhaitable dans notre tradition
constitutionnelle la politique fiscale
est une des prérogatives essentielles du
Parlement les travaux préparatoires de
l'article 11 de la Constitution indique
explicitement que que le constituant a
souhaité soustraire les lois de finances
au champ du référendum je ne crois pas
qu'il soit opportun de revenir sur ce
choix lever l'impôt est une des
prérogatives historiques et essentielles
du Parlement il faut qu'il la conserve
par ailleurs les nouvelles modalités du
contrôle exercé par le Parlement sur la
proposition de loi référendire présente
des incertitudes il s'agirait selon
cette proposition de remplacer le terme
examiné par le terme rejeté mais le
texte ne prévoit pas ce qu'il advient si
la proposition de loi est adoptée par
les deux ou par une seule d'entre elles
je crois donc que sur ce point comme sur
d'autres la réflexion mérite d'être
poursuivi le gouvernement monsieur le
sénateur chentrrel partage votre
objectif rendre plus accessible et plus
effectif le référendum d'initiative
partagé à ce titre je salue votre
initiative elle rejoint les objectifs
énoncés par le Président de la
République dans son discours du 4
octobre 2023 lors du 65e anniversaire de
notre
Constitution lors de de ce discours le
président de la République a en effet
indiqué vouloir que les citoyens soit
davantage
sollicité et mieux associé notamment par
une réforme du référendum d'initiative
partagée le gouvernement entend mettre
en œuvre cette réforme au cœur de ce
projet il y aura la question des seuils
sur laquelle nous devrons encore
travailler mais la réflexion mérite
également d'être poursuivie en ce qui
concerne le champ référendaire j'observe
d'ailleurs monsieur le sénateur Chantrel
que vous n'avez pas souhaité y intégrer
les questions de société comme avait
fait le gouvernement dans un précédent
projet ce n'est sans doute pas la seule
option envisageable mais la question
devra être abordé par ailleurs il nous
faudra collectivement réfléchir à des
mécanismes efficaces pour éviter toute
situation de concurrence des légitimités
il n'est pas question de permettre à des
initiatives citoyennes de revenir sur un
travail tout juste accompli par le
Parlement de même il n'est pas question
de permettre au Parlement de revenir sur
une loi référendaire tout juste adoptée
d'autres questions sont peut-être
envisagé afin d'éviter que le référendum
d'initiative partagé n'oppose les
citoyens aux parlementaires au
lieu de les associer mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs sur toutes ces questions
qui d'évidence ne sont pas tranché il
nous faudra parvenir à dégager des
lignes de consensus
et je suis convaincu que nous les
trouverons mais aujourd'hui et à ce
stade de nos réflexions collective je ne
peux être favorable à cette proposition
de loi constitutionnelle car je crois
que les travaux concernant la future
révision constitutionnelle sont toujours
en cours la réflexion concernant
l'article 11 mérite en effet d'être
prolongé et précisé je sais que le Sénat
il prend d'ailleurs toute sa part sous
l'égide du président Larcher par
ailleurs la niche socialiste
d'aujourd'hui ou la niche communiste du
mois dernier qui ont chacun compté une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
démontre l'engagement de la chambre
haute sans qui je le rappelle il ne
peut-être touché à notre texte fondateur
c'est pourquoi je forme le vœux que
demain nous puissions nous retrouver
autour d'un projet de réforme
constitutionnel qui constituera une
grande avancée pour notre modèle
démocratique c'est l'objectif fixé par
le président de la
République merci monsieur le ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
boncarer du groupe Union centriste pour
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
reconnaissons à nos collègues
socialistes le mérite de nous poser la
question d'une évolution du du
référendum d'initiative partagé et de
nous obliger à la fois une réflexion
toujours utile mais à une forme de
clarification il y aurait beaucoup de
choses passionnantes à évoquer sur
démocratie participative et démocratie
représentative nous sommes nombreux à
penser que la démocratie participative
est une pratique plutôt qu'un sujet
institutionnel et bien sûr sur la place
du référendum pour lequel chers
collègues vous avez rappelé l'article 3
de notre Constitution j'aurais tendance
à vous dire que le référendum est
d'abord un outil de solution par rapport
à une crise plutôt qu'un mode normal de
législation mais il me semble plus
simple dans le dé les brefs délis de de
6 minutes de rentrer directement dans
votre dans votre proposition et je
voudrais faire quelques observations au
fur et à mesure de de l'avancement de ce
que pourrait être un référendum
initiative partagée petit temp 15/5e des
membres du Parlement vous proposez de
diminuer de moitié ce n'est pas un sujet
Philippe B vous l'a indiqué les cinq
propositions de référendum initiative
partagé ont tout été soutenu par au
moins 200 parlementaires pas de
difficulté là-dessus 2è sujet
chronologiquement le contrôle du Conseil
constitutionnel il vérifie ce seuil il
vérifie que l'objet du référendum de
l'initiative rentre bien dans le cadre
de l'article 11 dans ces 3e et 6e alinéa
et il vérifie qu'aucune disposition
n'est contraire à la Constitution un
premier arrêt là-dessus il y a un risque
évident de conflit de légitimité si nos
concitoyens se voient expliquer qu'ils
ont la possibilité t de consulter et de
s'exprimer par voie référendum et de
découvrir chemin faisant que le Conseil
constitutionnel leur dit non ce n'est
pas possible parce que vous vous Ortez à
des dispositions constitutionnelles il
me paraîtrait essentiel d'aborder à
amant ce risque de conflit de légitimité
troème point le soutien l'acceptation
par le Conseil constitutionnel ouvre une
période de 9 mois pour recueillir c'est
un1è des électeurs inscrits chacun l'a
dit 4 millions à quelqu c'est beaucoup 1
million peut-être pas assez on sent bien
que il peut y avoir une solution quelque
part aux alentours de 2 millions
d'électeurs 4è point attirer l'attention
de nos collègues du groupe socialiste
sur peut-être une notutre faiblesse de
leur proposition le fait qu'il n'y a pas
d'étude d'impact constitutionnelle si
vous imaginez une proposition àocation
constitutionnelle issue de nos
concitoyens sans être passé par le
Conseil d'État sans avoir eu d'analyse
quant à ses conséquences pratique je
trouve l'exercice un peu hasardeux dans
une maison où nous ne cessons de dire
quelle est l'importance des études
d'impact je vous suggère de vous poser
cette question peut-être sous l'git du
Parlement 5ièmement vous dire que
examiner par le Parlement ou rejeté il
serait important de d'être plus précis
et je pense que Philippe B vous a donné
une analyse à laquelle vous devrez être
particulièrement attentif l'idée que le
référendum d'initiative partagé serait
possible justement parce que le
Parlement l'a rejeté conduit alors là au
choc de légitimité dans toute sa
splondeur puisque c'est parce que le
Parlement refuse que l'on vient devant
nos concitoyens il y a des moyens
probblement plus habiles de concilier
les deux ément voittir également votre
attention sur le fait que quand on dit
le Parlement dois-je comprendre que
c'est la Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
ce qui est la rédaction classique et
donc j'attire l'attention de mes
collègues sénateurs sur le fait que
pourrait être envisagé une disposition
en miroir de l'article 89 l'article 89
le garde des saau l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure c'est l'accord de l'assemblée
national et du Sénat je n'écarte pas non
plus que vous puissiez avoir cette
réflexion dans le cadre du référendum
d'initiative partagée vous dire
également que si le Parlement doit être
saisi il me semblerait raisonnable qu'il
puisse adopt mais qu'il puisse amender
ou compléter si un jour il doit y avoir
un référendum d'initiative partagé il me
paraisserait assez raisonnable que la
question posée aux Français puisse avoir
pu faire l'objet d'un examen et puisse
avoir été complété par le Parlement vous
dire aussi en ce qui concerne l'objet
que le fait de vouloir intégrer la
politique fiscale dans le champ de
l'article 11 me chaque moins qu'il n'a
choqué monsieur le rapporteur ou
monsieur le garde d saau il est vrai que
la fiscalité est une prérogative
traditionnelle du du Parlement à
l'inverse je peux aussi soutenir que le
consentement à l'impôt est une base de
la démocratie et interroger nos
concitoyens sur un sujet fiscal ne me
paraît pas forcément anormal et je
ségrait à nos collègues du groupe
socialiste de ne pas être allé sur le
terrain d'une extension au sujet de
société ou alors là on aborderait des
référendums extrêmement clivants et
répondre par ouiou par non des sujets
complexes et très cvants me paraît très
trèsusant ensuite il y a des problèmes
de délai je permet éventuellement
d'attirer votre attention sur l'intérêt
qu'il pourrait y avoir entre le moment
où le président de la République décide
est obligé de recourir au référendum
dans le cadre qu'on vient d'écrire et
celui-ci tout référendum du suppose à
mon avis une certaine réflexion et je ne
serais pas opposé à ce qu'il y ait un
délai entre les deux moyant ces
observations je suis peut-être un peu
moins pessimiste que ce qui a pu être
exprimé je crois que le
référenduminitiative partagé ne serait
pas impossible dans notre dans notre
pays et en particulier pourrait être
envisagé dans les périodes de
cohabitation merci de votre attention
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent notre collègue GUID benaroche
pour 4
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames Messieurs les auteurs
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
cette proposition de loi sur les
référendum d'initiativ partagé euh
concerne un processus qui a été créé
récemment on l'a dit mais qui n'a jamais
abouti à ce jour comme cela a été
rappeler de nombreuses conditions
interprétation jurisprudentielle du
Conseil constitutionnel en sent la
raison la présente proposition de loi a
pour but d'y remédier et de rendre
effectif cet outil d'exercice de la
souveraineté nationale bien sûr cette
proposition ne sera pas votée quand on
sait qu'au Sénat même des mesures telles
que l'extension du droit de pétition
pour le ciseux ou la désignation de
membres de convention citoyennees par
tirage au sort pose problème ce texte
propose CQ changements au critères
actuels qui se sont avérés trop
restrictif l'élargissement des champs
d'tel référendum sur lequel notre groupe
reste très prudent puisque euh
d'efficience de délibération d'échange
de points de vue ou d'expertise risque
réel lié à des manipulations décisions
discriminante en fonction du contexte et
de l'état de la société expression
favorisée du populisme nous init à cette
prudence pour autant la proposition des
auteurs est une façon de répondre à
l'interprétation trop stricte du Conseil
constitutionnel les auteurs danst le
même but souhaitent supprimer le terme
réforme oui les référendum d'initiatives
partagées doivent se concentrer sur des
changements importants pour les citoyen
mais encore une fois ce terme réforme a
fait l'objet d'interprétations diverses
par rapport au droits existant et non
par rapport au futur état de ce droit
deux autres mesures proposent d'abaisser
les seuils de signatures requises à la
fois des parlementaires et des citoyens
nous soutenant cette démarche en
particulier celle sur la baisse du
nombre de citoyens les expériences de
nos voisins nous y acitent mais aussi
l'ambition d'une effectivité d'une
rapidité dans la mise en œuvre du
référendum les auteurs souhaitent aussi
introduire une nouvelle procédure de
rejet par le Parlement un rejet express
de la proposition notre hébicyle s
souvent élevé à juste titre sur son
impossibilité de se prononcer de manière
expresse sur les textes de ratification
l'accord CTA par exemple cette
modification est essentielle et
engagerait clairement la responsabilité
du Parlement enfin la proposition de loi
propose une coélaboration partagéeune
initiative pouvant émaner des citoyens
puis être partagé et reprise par le
Parlement corrigeant à juste titre la
symmétrie actuelle notre société va mal
la démocratie représentative souffre de
bien des manières mais le ressenti
légitime par nos concitoyens d'un
déficier d'une défaillance de la
démocratie de la démocratie ne fait que
s'amplifier chamb des territoires nous
le savons bien de plus en plus de
français mais aussi d'élus locaux se
sont trop éloignés des discussions et
des décisions qui affectent leur
quotidien nous avons souvent ici pu
défendre le rôle essentiel du local le
besoin d'une différenciation nous
n'adhérons pas à une vision
concurrentielle de l'exercice de la
souveraineté le Parlement dans sa
légitimité n qu'une forme d'exercice de
la souveraineté nationale une forme
essentielle certes mais qui n'est pas et
qui ne doit pas être la seule il est
grand temps d'agir de nouveaux modes
d'expression citoyen doiv être
expérimentés certains d'ailleurs l'ont
déjà fait à l'échelle des territoires
des commune en particulier amplifiant ce
mouvement en permettant dans le cadre de
la loi de nombreuses nouvelles
expérimentations nous pensons que la
réflexion vers plus de démocratie
participative et de démocratie directe
tant au niveau national que local est
une nécessité nous pensons que le
référendum doit pouvoir être utilisé
dans un juste équilibre de préservation
de la cohésion nationale sans risque de
voir remettre en cause des acquis
majeurs et essentiels notre groupe pense
que toute modification des modalités de
référendum doivent bien sûr prévenir les
conflits de délibération entre deux
expressions de la souveraineté une
directe via le référendum par exemple et
via le Parlement mais les trop grands
écarts d'aspirations entre les élus et
les citoyens N cite un Boyen coactif
prévu dans notre
Constitution Michel Debray on a cité
tout à l'heure Jacques Sirac donc on
cite beaucoup de gens à droite rappeler
la seule souveraineté c'est le peuple et
le président de la République fait appel
à lui en cas de conflit nous avons bien
vu que l'appel à la souveraineté du
peuple via la dissolution et de
nouvelles élections est trop peu employé
pour des raisons bien sûr très
politicienne le référendum pour être cet
outil moins soumis au Bonvouloir d'une
seule personne F le président de la
République aussi notre groupe soutiendra
cette proposition de loi merci chers
collègues la parole est à la présidente
k Kirman pour 4
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le garde des saau mes chers collègues
tout d'abord le texte que nous examinons
soulève de N nombreuses questions des
questions qui inévitablement mais cela a
déjà été dit mérite bien plus que 2
heures de débat et je pense que nous en
convenons toutes et tous pour traiter
cette question il nous faut nous mettre
d'accord sur les constats et le premier
d'entre eux est celui d'une crise
démocratique forte que nous traversons
oui la démocratie française est malade
elle est malade d'une trop grande
concentration des pouvoirs dans les
mains de l'exécutif malade aussi d'un
par Parlement qui n'est pas libre de
l'organisation de ses travaux elle est
malade en tout point mais aussi en tout
lieu car la démocratie ce n'est pas
uniquement au niveau national c'est
aussi la démocratie communale la
démocratie sociale auquelle nous sommes
très attachés c'est précisément dans ce
contexte de crise démocratique de crise
des institutions représentatives que les
différents appels à tenir des
référendums ici ou là doivent être
compris le deuxième constat tient au
limite intrinsèque au référendum lequel
est entaché d'une tradition césariste
verticale qui fait que nous restons à
première vue méfiant à son égard quoi
qu'on en dise le rip est aussi un modèle
un mode vertical d'exercice du pouvoir
car même en cas de proposition émanant
de parlementaire c'est le président qui
la soumet à référendum c'est même un de
ces pouvoir propre conformément à
l'article de la constitution d'une
manière générale le le référendum ne
doit surtout pas à nos yeux être
sacralisé ni être perçu comme une
solution miracle tout d'abord un
référendum c'est une campagne
référendaire et de fait une campagne
référendaire est binaire le peuple ne
pourra répondre que par oui ou par non
et ce qu'en tant que parlementaire
disposant d'un droit d'amendement nous
avons du mal à concevoir parce qu'il va
à l'inverse de la nécessité absolu de
chercher des constructions
communes il ne garantit d'ailleurs en
rien une hausse de la participation
électorale un référendum c'est aussi en
théorie une égalité de temps de parole
pour les deux camps mais là encore mes
chers collègues n'oublions pas la
problématique actuelle de concentration
des médias que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et ce d'autant qu'il n'y a
plus de culture référendaire en France
depuis le référendum de 2005 dont le
résultat a été
outrepassé par ailleurs la question des
sujets sur lequel un référendum peut
porter est éminemment complexe et
convenons-en le terme de réforme est mal
venu il faudrait à minima le définir
avec précision en en commission notre
rapporteur a dit et je le cite que le
référendum doit concerner des sujets
vitauxx pour l'avenir de la nation et
qu'il n'était donc pas favorable à sa
banalisation la question je crois sera
posée dans quelques jour le 12 le 12
décembre à travers l'examen de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
portée ici par la droite sénatoriale et
donc nous aurons encore l'occasion de
revenir sur ces sujets le troisième et
dernier constat c'est celui du poids du
Conseil constitutionnel dans la
procédure du rip c'est pour nous un des
points les plus importants de la
procédure si cette intervention doit en
effet être repenser il ne peut suffire
comme certains le proposent de s'en
passer purement et simplement pour notre
part nous estimons que cette
intervention devrait peut-être se borner
à vérifier l'objet du Rip ainsi que les
soutiens des électeurs et des
parlementaires puis enfin s'assurer que
les droits et libertés fondamentaux sont
respectés pour conclure il est évident
que le mécanisme actuel du Rip est
grippé le seuil des 4,9 millions
d'électeurs est d'évidence
inatteignablees celui des 185
parlementaires ne nous semble pas quant
à lui être un véritable obstacle nous
souhaitons donc remercier le groupe
socialiste d'avoir ouvert ce débat parce
que nous prenons cette proposition de
loi d'appel et après je crois un débat
qui a traversé tous les groupes nous
voterons pour cette proposition de loi
merci la parole est à présent notre
collègue Henry Cabanel pour le groupe
RDSE pour 4
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues
monsieur Rocard répondant Carl Z0 résuma
ainsi un référendum c'est aussi une
excitation nationale où on met tout le
monde dans le même pot on pose une
question les gens s'en posent d'autres
et viennent voter en fonction de raisons
qui n'ont plus rien à voir avec la
question tandis que Françoise Girou
exprimé ses mêmes doutes dans cet arrivé
hier dans un référendum les gens ne
répondent jamais à la question qu'on
leur pose ils donnent leur adhésion ou
la refuse à celui qui la
pose un récent sondage publié jeudi
dernier par BVA pour RTL témoigne
pourtant de l'intérêt des Français pour
cet outil ils sont 88 % à être favorable
au fait de réaliser un référendum sur
des sujets de société concernant le
référendum d'initiative partagée qui
nous réunit aujourd'hui autour de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle de
notre collègue Yan Chantrel il sera
heureux d'apprendre que parmi les
personnes interrogées 82 %
approuveraient le fait de donner aux
citoyens l'initiative de l'organisation
d'un RIP et 71 % seraiit favorable à la
baisse du nombre de signatures
nécessaires à sa mise en place voilà
donc un texte qui colle à l'actualité
puisque le président de la République
l'a mis également au cœur des rencontres
de
Saint-Denis ces deux mesures publicité
dans ce sondage font caisse de
résonnance rendication des gilets jaunes
en 2018 qu'il présentait comme une
solution pour donner la parole au peuple
via la création d'un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ou
populaire on peut comprendre la défiance
de ce même peuple dans les référendums
existant actuellement quand on se
remémore le fiasco de celui concernant
le traité établissant une Constitution
pour l'Europe initiée par Jacques Chirak
en 2005 souvenez-vous le nom l'emporte
avec 54 67 % des suffrages exprimés
résultat 2 ans plus tard contournant par
voie parlementaire de ce rejet
démocratique par la ratification du
traité de Lisbonne en 2007 par Monsieur
Nicolas
Sarkozi cet exemple montre les limites
de l'exercice avec 69,37 % de taux de
participation ce référendum avait
rassemblé les Français autour d'un sujet
très technique car ils y ont vu
l'opportunité de rejeter la poli que
nationale un vote sanction plus qu'une
réponse à la question ceci venant
corroborer les deux citations de du
début de mon
intervention lorsque il s'agit de sujet
de société il faut donc raison garder un
seul oui ou non ne me paraît pas sérieux
pour traiter des thèmes sensibles car la
vérité est souvent dans la nuance à
l'heure des réseaux sociaux des fake new
et des théories de complot vers quelle
information iront les citoyens pour se
faire une opinion
une vraie sensibilisation devit être
devit être mise en place en amont mon
groupe le RDSE défend plutôt une usage
tempéré et limité des ripes car la loi
doit s'écrire au Parlement il ne
soutient pas la diminution du nombre de
parlementaires car pour une cause juste
il est facile de trouver 185
parlementaires par exemple l'avenir de
l'hôpital public en réunissant peine en
août 2021 des parlementaires d'horizons
diverses je suis pour ma part favorable
à l'abaissement du seuil des citoyens
seuil qui doit être étudié pour qu'il
soit raisonnable et représentatif car si
j'adère aux bonnes intentions de
l'auteur qui veut offrir aux Français
plus de possibilités de s'exprimer dans
un contexte de défiance exacerbée envers
les élus et les institutions je pense
qu'il faut travailler sur d'autres
formes de démocratie et surtout à mon
sens encourager aussi les référendum
locaux qui vont accultirer les citoyens
dans cet outil fort d'une culture
commune sur le sujet ils trouve ils
contribueront aux solutions que seuls
les élus qui l'ont été via le suffrage
universel décideront car les
associations de citoyens ne remettent
pas en question la démocratie
représentative ciment de notre
démocratie je fini monsieur le Président
le groupe de travail sur les
institutions présidées par le Président
Larcher a intégré ce sujet dans son
programme cela permettra d'enrichir le
débat une PPL ne nous semble donc pas
plus adaptée mais elle a pour objet
quand même d'ouvrir le débat et je
remercie Monsieur notre collègue
Chantrel la réforme de nos institutions
doit être pranée globalement et pas en
silo je pense que les Français attendent
cela merci merci la parole est à notre
collègue tan Mohamed swali pour le
groupe RDPI pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
gardessau monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous sommes réuni pour
examiner la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle de notre collègue Yan
Chantrel et du groupe socialiste visant
à faciliter le déclenchement du
référendum d'initiative partagé si
l'origine du Rip est ancienne c'est la
réforme constitutionnelle de 2008 qui a
modifier l'article 11 de la Constitution
pour y introduire une nouvelle forme de
référendum an sur une initiative
provenant d'un5e de parlementaires soit
185 députés et ou sénateurs et soutenu
par 10 % du corp électoral soit 4,8
millions de personnes aujourd'hui en
outre ce dispositif impose que la
proposition de loi soumise à référendum
ne porte que sur les domaines énumérés
par l'article 11 et ne puisse pas avoir
pour objet l'abrogation d'une
disposition législative promulguée
depuis moins d'un an ou un sujet rejeté
par par référendum il y a moins de 2 ans
aujourd'hui nous pouvons sur tous les
bancs de cette assemblée nous accorder
sur un constat les modalités de mise en
œuvre du Rip sont trop complexes à tel
point qu'aucune proposition
parlementaire n'est jamais parvenue à
valider l'ensemble de ces conditions et
qu'aucun RIP n'a à ce jour pu être
organisé malgré cinq tentatives
l'opportunité d'une réflexion sur
l'assouplissement des modalités de sa
mise en œuvre n'est par conséquent pas
contesté le président de la République
avait d'ailleurs envisagé une
simplification de la procédure dès 2019
et à ce titre je salue l'initiative de
notre collègue Yann Chantrel qui
s'inscrit dans cet objectif et propose
en outre d'élargir le champ du
référendum d'abaisser les seuils de
signatures requis à 93 parlementaires et
1 million d'électeurs de créer une
deuxème procédure de référendum
d'initiative partagée symétrique à celle
prévue aujourd'hui et enfin d'imposer la
tenue d'un référendum d'initiative
partagée sauf en cas de rejet du texte
par le Parlement cependant je pense
qu'en matière de démocratie
participative tout doit être question
d'équilibre équilibre qu'il est parfois
difficile de tenir entre gardefous
nécessaire pour limiter les risques de
contournement du Parlement et bon
fonctionnement de cet outil participatif
légitimement réclamé par la population
en l'état le le présent texte n'atteint
pas cet équilibre tout d'abord parce que
vendredi dernier la 3e édition des
Rencontres de Saint-Denis devait être
l'occasion d'aborder ces questions de
l'élargissement du champ du référendum
et de la facilitation de l'organisation
du référendum d'initiative partagé trois
grandes formations politiques n'ont pas
pris part à cet événement et il est
apparu au cours des discussions que la
réflexion n'était pas mû les
participants n'ayant pas réussi à
trouver un certain un terrain d'entendre
sur ces sujets ensuite parce qu'un
certain nombre de points parce qu'un
certain nombre de points contenus dans
cette proposition de loi constitutionnel
sont susceptibles d'entraîner des
conséquences dont on ne mesure pas
suffisamment la porté un tel abaissement
du nombre de soutiens d'électeurs à 100
million lorsque la France en compte 48
pourrait ouvrir la porte à des
manipulation ou à des abus les
signatures recueillies doivent refléter
la volonté du peuple et non celle d'une
minorité organisée de plus le référendum
d'initiative partagée a été conçu pour
aborder des questions d'une importance
exceptionnelle et nationale la
suppression du terme réforme associé à
la réduction du seuil de signature
pourra diluer l'impact et la
signification de cet instrument
démocratique le transformant en un moyen
plus fréquemment utilisé pour des
questions de portée local ou moins
crucial en outre chaque question
controversé pourrait déclencher un
référendum ce qui pourrait entraîner une
instabilité politique et des
incertitudes juridique il est impératif
de s'assurer que les décisions cruciales
pour notre nation ne soient pas prises
dans un climat d'urgence mais après un
examen minutieux et une délibération
approfondie enfin je suis juriste pas
constitutionnaliste mais il me semble
qu'une telle modification des contours
du référendum iniative partagée
nécessite la révision d'autres articles
de la Constitution et pas seulement de
l'article 11 ne serait-ce que parce que
les compétences du Conseil
constitutionnel s'en trouveraient changé
de mémoire le projet de loi
constitutionnel pour un nouveau pour un
renouveau de la vie politique de 2019
proposé d'ailleurs de créer un nouveau
titre 11 intitulé de la participation
citoyenne pour conclure mon propos bien
que la démocratie participative soit une
valeur fondamentale que nous souhaitons
encourager nous devons approcher toute
modification constitutionnelle avec une
extrême prudence avant de soutenir une
telle proposition nous devons réfléchir
attentivement aux implications à long
terme pour notre nation et pour la
démocratie que nous cherchons à protéger
et à renforcer trancher une question
aussi complexe pendant pendant les 2
heures réservées à l'espace d'un groupe
parlementaire nous semble précipité le
groupe RDPI aura en l'état une position
neutre sur ce sujet qui requiert à notre
sens plus de maturation pour sauf pour 7
d'entre nous nous abstiendrons merci
chers collègues la parole est à notre
collègue Éric kirouche pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 6
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le président Président
Monsieur le gardessau monsieur le
rapporteur la question du référendum a
animé les débats d'entre de tours de la
présidentiel qui opposait le candidat
Renaissance à la candidate d'extrême
droite Emmanuel Macron avait notamment
annoncé à l'époque ne pas exclure une
consultation des Français sur son projet
de recherche de pardon de retraite une
excellente proposition qu'il a
courageusement concrétisé comme tout le
monde sait de la même manière au cours
de son mandat précédent il avait
envisagé de soumettre les positions de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
au référendum là aussi ça a été
courageusement mis en application quant
à Marine Le Pen elle ne proposait pas
grand-chose constitutionnellement sinon
la possibilité de mettre en place un RIC
qui permettrait de consulter les
Français sur des sujets de société
surprise sur la priorité nationale par
exemple ou sur l'immigration toute
ressemblance avec des propositions
actuelles et bien entendu fortuititees
cette proposition de consultation sur
l'immigration a été temporairement
partagée par Emmanuel Macron qui l'a
annoncé avec le talon d'un horlogé en
plein examen du projet de loi
d'immigration avant de le retirer ce
n'est pas la première fois d'ailleurs
qu'il rebrousse chemin sur la question
de la transformation de nos institutions
en 2019 il avait déjà proposé de
modifier les disposition du champ
référendaire et du référendum
d'initiative partagé et là encore il a
enterré ses possibilités dans après les
rencontres de
saint-en si on résume la pratique
référendaire française renfoie à un
instrument qui est avant tout
présidentiel dont la pratique est
délaissé depuis un peu plus de 20 ans
cela distingue notre pays des autres
démocraties occidentales où le peuple
peut se saisir sur un champ plus vaste
de sujet et où le recours à cet outil
est bien plus fréqu
le problème du référendum en France on
l'a dit c'est qu'il a une tendance et
une dérive plébiscitaire depuis l'Empire
et après cependant monsieur learde des
saau vous avez parlé de l'article 11
mais tout au départ dans les travaux
préparatoires de la Constitution le
champ de l'article 11 était bien plus
étendu et ce n'est qu'avec un accord
entre les forces politiques et le
général de Gaulle qu'il s'est vu
restreindre on comptait donc donner une
place à ce
dispositif cependant notre pays n'a pas
connu de référendum depuis 2005 malgré
l'initiative que représente le
référendum d'initiative partagée
introduit en 2008 six tentatives six
échecs d'une certaine façon malgré une
fois la possibilité d'avoir atteint 1
million de signatures ce ne sont plus
des gardesfous ce sont des murailles en
matière de seuil en matière de signature
en matière de dispositions
réglementaires nous ne nous satisfaisons
pas de ce déficit démocratique et on
considère en ce qui nous concerne que il
ne s'agit pas d'un outil contre la
démocratie il ne s'agit pas de
considérer comme le disait Nicolas
Sarkozi que le peuple n'est pas assez
intelligent en soulignant l'intérêt de
cette mesure on l'a dit l'article 3 de
notre Constitution divise la
souveraineté entre d'une part les
représentant d'autre part la voix du
référendum si l'on n'utilise pas les
outils démocratiques dont nous disposons
nous les remettons en cause et c'est ce
qui se passe dans le cas du du
référendum d'initiative partager il faut
que les citoyens puissent donner leur
avis puissent donner un avis reprenons
les arguments qui sont énoncés contre la
proposition de notre collègue Yann
Chantrel on ne pourrait pas étendre aux
politiques
fiscales puisque cela relève du
Parlement ça a été dit encore par vous
monsieur le garde des Dessau ce de se
réfère peu de cas alors de l'article 13
et de l'article 14 de de la DDH sur
l'égalité et le consentement à l'impôt
qui sont intégrés au bloc de
constitutionnalité je diraiis également
à nos collègues les républicains que la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
qu'il propose ne s'encombre pas des
mêmes subtilités loin de là nous
divergeons sur les priorités celle de la
gauche c'est la justice fiscale pour
plus d'égalité celle de la droite c'est
l'immigration sur la modification des
seuils je ne vais pas aller très loin
quand on considère qu'il s'agit juste de
déclencher la procédure on peut voir que
dans d'autres pays notamment le Portugal
les Pays-Bas ou l'Italie et bien les
seuils sont comparables cela ne pose pas
de problème sur la possibilité d'une
initiative citoyenne qui serait trop
complexe je rappelle que cette
possibilité a été proposée en 2008 par
des députés socialistes ainsi que par
des sénateurs de droite qui a priori
n'étaient pas de dangereux adistes enfin
sur la question du verrou technique lié
à l'examen d'une proposition de loi
référendaire par les assemblées nous
avons fait nous avons fait introduire
une disposition dans le règlement du
Sénat la proposition de notre collègue
permet de lever toutes les difficultés
alors pour paraphraser Bertle breche ce
n'est pas parce que les citoyens ne
pourraient ne pas être d'accord avec le
gouvernement qu'il faut dissoudre le
peuple la possibilité que nous mon c'est
de rendre la parole aux citoyens pour
cela il leur faut il nous faut leur
donner des modalités d'expression et de
participation c'est le sens de la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
chanrel et du groupe socialiste parce
que nous pensons que donner la parole au
peuple c'est lui reconnaître sa
légitimité de constituant et donc rendre
ces lettres de noblesse à notre
démocratie française je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Madame lauan jand pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous connaissons tous
l'histoire turbulente du référendum en
France un moyen qui a beaucoup été
utilisé au 19e siècle comme un outil
plébiscitaire et souvent au détriment de
la démocratie elle-même c'est
précisément cette pratique qui a motivé
l'encadrement de son usage dans la
constitution de la 5e République pour
permettre
d'articuler l'exercice de la
souveraineté nationale par le biais des
représentants du peuple avec
l'expression directe de la voix de ce
dernier dont la prise en considération
et l'essence même de la
démocratie ainsi la remise en question
des seuils de saisine fixés à 20 % des
parlementaires soutenu par 10
% non excusez-moi afin d'assurer cette
conciliation entre le bon fonctionnement
des mécanismes parlementaires et
l'attente légitime de consultation des
électeurs la Constitution dispose donc
en son article 3 que la souveraineté
nationale cela a été dit c'est pour ça
que je voulais passer très vite mais je
préfère quand même le redire appartient
au représentants du peuple et au
référendum mais aussi au terme de son
article 39 que l'initiative des lois
appartient concurremment et c'est
important au Premier ministre et au
membres du Parlement souhaitant élargir
les possibilités d'organisation d'un
référendum d'initiative partagé N
collègues du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain souhaite
altérer cet équilibre constitutionnel et
l'équilibre du pouvoir dans cette
démocratie à la française la
modification de l'article 11 relatif au
référendum dit ordinaire tel qu'elle est
souhaité dans ce texte soulève
d'importimportant problématique tant sur
le plan de la technique juridique comme
cela a été dit par notre rapporteur que
sur le fond et justement par rapport à
ce qu'implique un véritable débat
démocratique tout d'abord le rapporteur
l'a rappelé je passerai rapidement la
nature récente du dispositif qui n'a que
8 ans de facto empêche de tirer des
conclusions péremptoire sur son bon
fonctionnement ainsi la remise en
question des seuils je le
disais semble
prématuré ceux-ci ont précisément été
conçus pour servir de filtre et éviter
le contournement du Parlement ensuite
les problématiques soulevées par la
possibilité de collecter les signatures
avant le contrôle du Conseil
constitutionnel suscite les inquiétudes
importantes quant au moment et aux
modalités d'exercice de ce contrôle en
effet cette inversion de logique
pourrait entraîner des conséquences qui
vont bien au-delà d'un simple ajustement
procédural en effet elle remet en
question la séquence délibérée par le
constituant laquelle vis est à assurer
une articulation harmonieuse entre les
différentes étapes du processus
référendaire ainsi convient-il d'acter
ici de la nécessité d'une réflexion
beaucoup plus approfondie comme beaucoup
de mes collègues l'ont dit avant moi car
pour une réforme substantielle il faut
prendre en compte les impacts de toute
révision de l'article 11 sur la
cohérence globale de l'édifice juridique
qui est notre Constitution et à minima
sur les articles 39 et 89 de notre
Constitution par ailleurs la proposition
de loi remplace le mécanisme du mise de
la mise pardon au référendum contrainte
en ce que l'on peut appeler une mise au
référendum obligée dans tous les cas
autre que le rejet parler de chambre
certains de mes collègues l'ont dit
également c'est un véritable le problème
puisque en fait la démarche imposée par
ce mécanisme implique qu' texte voté par
les deux assemblées se trouve malgré
cela nécessairement soumis au référendum
en l'état actuel du droit il n'y a que
l'article 89 qui a qui qui prévoit une
procédure exceptionnelle qui permet donc
de ne pas organiser un référendum sur
cette baseel le texte ajoute en plus une
complexité du fait qu'il remet en
question le le rôle du Parlement
bicaméral et celui de la navette
parlementaire donc je n'y reviendrai pas
ça a été suffisamment dit mais au-delà
les défis considérables que soulève la
question de toucher à l'article 11 nous
pose problème au niveau de notre groupe
puis que ce n'est malheureusement
aujourd'hui qu'un débat tronqué trop
rapide que nous pouvons avoir sur sur
cet article 11 et ce débat mérite d'être
beaucoup plus approfondi comme cela a
été dit l'existence de travaux
concomitants du Sénat lui-même
est un point important puisque notre
président Gérard Larcher a lancé un
groupe de travail sur les institutions
et il convient donc pour assurer un tel
débat assurer sa qualité et surtout en
assurer la pertinence de prendre du
temps et nous devons l'aborder avec une
grande prudence le référendum
d'initiative partagé doit demeurer un
instrument équilibré préservant
l'intégrité de notre système
représentatif tout en offrant aux
citoyens une voix d'expression directe
lorsque cela est véritablement utile en
effet la démocratie directe ne doit
jamais être un prétexte pour dévitaliser
le parlementarisme qui est au cœur de
nos institutions républicaine en guise
de conclusion mes chers collègues il est
impératif que de reconnaître que cette
proposition de loi présentée aujourd'hui
et je crois que tout le monde partage ce
sentiment le mérite de montrer que le
débat sur l'article 11 doit être mené
mais elle est tout aussi inaboutie
techniquement qu'inopportune vous l'avez
compris les modifications proposées
soulèv en réalité des questions de fond
bien plus importantes qu'un simple
abaissement des seuils de recours au
référendum il est donc préférable de ne
pas adopter ce texte de poursuivre les
échanges et réflexions entamé dans le
cadre des différentes instances et
notamment ici au Sénat pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe les républicains
suivra la vie du rapporteur de la
commission et ne votera pas cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane Ravier pour les
sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun
groupe
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors que
la démocratie représentative est
piétinée par le recours abusif ehémisme
à l'article 493 et que nos présidents de
la République successifs ne consultent
plus les Français par référendum donnons
la capacité au peuple souverain
d'initier une procédure référendaire qui
puisse réellement aboutir il est
paradoxal de voir les hommes politiques
continuellement consulter l'opinion
publique en commandant ou en
interprétant des sondages et ne pas
accepter de s'en remettre à l'initiative
du peuple et à son verdict le référendum
d'initiative partagé actuelle est un
hochet donné aux citoyens en 2008 pour
faire croire en la bonne volonté d'un
exécutif coupable d'avoir bafoué le nom
au référendum de 2005 en R i ifiant le
traité de Lisbonne en 2007 l'usage a
montré qu'il était inapplicable vous ne
pouvez pas vous Draper de gaulisme en
permanence et refuser de gouverner comme
lui 10 ans au pouvoir et quatre
référendums à son actif depuis bientôt
19 ans Nicolas Sarkozi François Hollande
et Emmanuel Macron sont passés à
l'Élysée en oubliant la voix du peuple
le soir même de leur élection c'est
aussi cela qui nourrit l'abstention
aggrave la crise civique dénous le lien
de confiance rabougri la démocratie
représentative et attise les violences
je suis un parlementaire et je pense
qu'au côté des Français de tout bord
gilets jaune ou bonis rouge nous devons
être entendus en nous exprimant dans les
urnes lors des consultation nationale
autre que l'élection des représentants
le débat parlementaire reprend son sens
et sa vitalité quand notre institution
se laisse l'opportunité de sortir des
méandres de la procédure parlementaire
cet automne à l'occasion des 65 ans de
la Constitution il est donc temps de
faire un adjournento démocratique non
pas en convoquant les chefs de parti à
un entre sois mais en convoquant les
Français sur des sujets qui les
intéressent même si vous les jugez
démagogique monsieur le ministre nous
avons appris à l'issue du dernier entre
soois de Saint-Denis que le consensus
était fait autour du refus d'un
élargissement du champ du référendum
voilà le plus petit dénominateur commun
entre les partis politiques français
brider la vie du peuple voilà le mal
français ou plutôt le mal fait aux
Français le monopole des partis sur la
délibération politique et désespérant
les français se sentent dépossédés
méprisés bayonnés le référendum sur
l'immigration évoqué par le chef de
l'État le 3 novembre est donc abandonné
par le chef de l'État alors que certains
fantasm une créolisation mais que notre
pays est soumis à un processus de
crépolisation avancé conséquence
directes de sa politique d'immigration
quoi de mieux qu'un référendum pour
faire peuple qui de mieux que le peuple
peut définir la politique d'immigration
confisquée par les juges et traités
européens et internationaux qui de mieux
que le peuple peut acquesser ou refuser
sa dislocation et sa disparition sans
référend nous sortons du 21e siècle pour
revenir aux zér des 3e et 4e républiques
dans lesquelles le Parlement et les
partis verrouillent les décisions on
sait comment cela fini sans révision
constitutionnelle notre inconséquence
mènera à la guerre civile ou à la 6e
république mélanchoniste synonyme de la
fin non seulement du pacte républicain
mais surtout surtout de la France c'est
pourquoi je soutiendrai ce projet de loi
merci la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Pierre Jean Rochette pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 4
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le garde des saau monsieur le
rapporteur la démocratie c'est le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple et
la souveraineté nationale c'est le
peuple peuple exerçant sa souveraineté
sans entrave disait le Général de Gaulle
en
1942 l'absence d'entrave ne signifie
évidemment pas l'absence de cadre
l'actuel article 11 de la Constitution
fixe plusieurs conditions à la mise en
œuvre du référendum notamment celui
d'initiative partagé l'article définit
avec précision le périmètre d'une telle
consultation il fixe également des
seuils minimaux de parlementaires de
citoyens pour la mise en œuvre de ce
dispositif 10% du corps électoral et 20
% des parlementaires nos collègues
socialistes nous invitent à élargir le
périmètre et à abaisser ses seuils la
justification les justifications
avancées sont claires il s'agit de
faciliter la consultation de nos
concitoyens sur les grands sujets
politiques ils estiment par ailleurs
qu'une telle facilitation est à même de
remédier au moins partiellement au
déclin de la participation de nos
concitoyens aux élections ces objectifs
sont méritoires nous regrettons tous le
recul de l'engagement démocratique dans
notre pays néanmoins la proposition de
de nos collègues se heurent à plusieurs
obstacles le président du Sénat comme ça
a été dit précédemment a relancé le
groupe de travail sur les sur les
institutions précisément sur la question
des référendum à non pas douter la
proposition de nos collègues socialistes
constitue une contribution de poids
cependant il est peut-être prématuré de
se prononcer sur de ces sujets avant que
nous soyons allés au bout de ce
processus le fait que jamais en 8 ans un
référendum d'initiative partagé ne soit
parvenu à être soutenu par 4,87 millions
d'électeurs fait dire à nos collègues
que ce seuil doit être abaissé nous n'en
faisons pas la même interprétation
au-delà du fait que 8 années constitue
une période relativement courte si on
raisonne en terme de de de la vie nos
Instit tion nous pensons que ces seuils
n'ont pas été atteints car la très
grande majorité de nos concitoyens ne
souhaitaent pas être consultés sur les
sujets en cause 1 million d'électeurs
représent 2 % du corps électoral de
notre pays est-il légitime qu'une si
faible proportion puisse imposer une
consultation au 98 % restant nous ne le
pensons pas que des minorités politique
manifestent leur opposition et expriment
leur revendication rien de plus légitime
en revanche il nous apparaîtrait injuste
qu'elle puisse imposer des consultations
intempestives d'autant plus lorsqu'un
contrôle ne ser lorsqu'aucun contrôle ne
sera effectué par le Conseil
constitutionnel et à forciori lorsque le
format binaire du référendum polarise
nécessairement en excluant toute
nuance nous connaissons les dangers du
populisme les auteurs de la présente
proposition appellent de leur vœux un
référendum sur une réforme des retraites
adopté par 493 mais le récuse lorsqu'il
s'agit d'autres sujets de société les
membres du groupe les indépendants sont
de fervants partisans de la démocratie
participative nous sommes convaincus que
la consultation de nos concitoyens sur
les politiques de notre pays doit rester
exceptionnelle si nous ne voulons pas
fragiliser davantage la légitimité du
travail
parlementaire au moment où le débat
politique se polarise il nous semble
essentiel de renforcer nos institutions
et leur stabilité nous voterons donc
contre pardon l'adoption de cette
proposition merci merci la discussion
générale est close la commission n'ayant
pas élaboré de texte nous passons à la
discussion de l'article unique de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
initiale je vais mettre au voix
l'article unique constituant l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle le vote sur l'article
vaudra vote sur l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi il y a-t-il des
demandes d'explication de vote monsieur
chanrel
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais faire répondre à quelques
quelques éléments qui ont été abordés
lors de de la discussion générale et
rappeler quand même que cette réforme du
Rip elle a été voulue avant tout
monsieur le rapporteur par votre
majorité de l'époque en 2008 c'est pas
nous qui l'avons mis dans la
Constitution c'est vous qui l'avez mis
dans la Constitution la seule chose que
nous nous proposons c'est de l'améliorer
soit vous c'est de la simplifier de la
rendre réalisable soit vous considérez
c'était une mauvaise disposition et vous
avez fait une erreur à l'époque et vous
revenez dessus soit vous considérez que
c'est une bonne disposition et vous
faites tout pour qu'elle puisse se
réaliser ce que vous avez dit dans votre
propos c'est que vous étiez finalement
que le Président de la République et on
en convient à beaucoup de pouvoirs donc
vous étiez contre l'élargissement de ces
pouvoirs donc j'imagine que vous voterez
contre la proposition de loi de Monsieur
rotillot au mois de décembre qui
lui-même je cite élargit le champ du
référendum à tout projet de loi ou tout
projet de loi organique donc y compris
également la question fiscale ensuite
sur les seuils des 185 parlementaires
vous dites ça n'a jamais été un frein
mais comment peut-on le savoir puisque
par nature elles n'ont pas pu être
déposé il y en a eu certainement un
certain nombre qui ont été portter à
notre connaissance sur le 100 million de
signature vous dites le seuil est trop
bas quand on regarde tous les les pays
qui pratiquent ce type de disposition
c'est un seuil qui n'est jamais atteint
tellement il est élevé 500000 en Italie
00 en Suisse donc 1 million de
signatures c'est encore très haut et
c'est très exigeant puisqu'il faut être
inscrit sur les listes électorales quand
vous regarder les pétitions qui sont en
ligne sur internet il y en a très peu
qui atteignent 1 million alors que
n'importe qui peutvent les signer même
des personnes anonym donc c'est un seuil
qui est très élevé et par contre sur la
question de l'examen qui remplace le
rejet bah bien évidemment le référendum
a lieu que si ça n'a été rejeté que par
les deux assemblées donc redonner
un petit peu il y a quand même beaucoup
de verrou et le Parlement est bien
évidemment toujours dans la boucle
puisque nous avons la possibilité de
nous y opposer mais ce n'est pas une
obligation c'est une possibilité donc ce
qu'on demande c'est juste de permettre
de simplifier ce que vous-même vous
aviez inscrit dans la Constitution pour
qu'on puisse travailler de faire avec
nos concitoyens mais pas les uns contre
les autres mais ensemble merci monsieur
chanrel je met au voix l'article unique
constituant l'ensemble le président
buffet
pour indiquer que si la Commission n'a
pas établi de texte qu'elle a souhaité
d'abord qu'il viennne au débat devant
l'Assemblée mais que par ailleurs
contenu de la situation elle avait mis
un avis négatif donc elle est contre ce
texte d lors qu'il va y avoir un scrutin
public il était important que nous
disions ce que nous en pensions monsieur
le Président canner
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
gardessau j'ai entendu avec beaucoup
d'attention l'intervention brillante du
rapporteur Philippe B pour dire voilà
voilà il faut prendre son temps
négotionons regardons dans le détail les
articles les uns après les autres voyons
ce qu'on peut trouver comme point
d'accord j'entends cette
prudence sûrement bienveillante monsieur
le rapporteur mais euh pourquoi ne pas
utiliser le même type d'argument sur un
autre texte que vous portez qui réforme
une constitution qui réforme la
Constitution le 12 décembre prochain la
PPLC retaille au buffet sur
l'immigration
vous y demandez quoi vous y demandez
l'intégration dans l'article 11 de des
questions migratoires vous
demandez
aussi de prendre en considération la
notion d'assimilation plutôt que
d'intégration vous vous remettez en
cause le droit du
sol et et tout ça excusez-moi au
canon donc vous pouvez nous critiquer en
disant mais vous allez trop vite trop
loin mais votre majorité sénatoriale
n'hésite pas sur d'autres sujets à
prendre un chemin bien plus en tout
cas conflictuel que celui que nous vous
proposons sur l'élargissement du Rip et
puis je n'ai pas oublié je n'ai pas
manqué de de voir que Monsieur
rotaot sur proposition qui lui avait été
faite de Monsieur Larcher président du
Sénat lui-même sur ma proposition
d'utiliser l'article 39 dernière alinéa
de la Constitution monsieur rotillot a
refusé
d'avoir un avis du Conseil d'État sur
cette PPLC donc de poids de mesures nous
le regrettons donc si vous êtes prudent
avec nous soyez prudent vous-même avec
les textes que vous portez au sein de la
majorité
sénatoriale merci monsieur le
rapporteur c'est exact monsieur le
Président canner je suis très prudent et
j'aurais souhaité que vous le fussiez
aussi parce que le référendum d'homme
peut apporter le meilleur comme le
pire nous sommes nous le Parlement de la
République nous savons ce que la
délibération parlementaire peut
permettre de produire comme consensus
dans une démocratie dont la verticalité
a souvent été contestée surtout au cours
des dernières années on constate que
l'augmentation des pouvoirs du Président
de la République
est effectivement une question qu'il
faut aborder avec prudence face à la
représentation nationale et par
conséquent nous devons être très
attentif parce que quand le sujet est
capital quand la question est une
question qui par sa nature même peut se
prêter à une réponse par oui ou par non
alors les deux principales conditions
sont remplies pour un référendum qu'il
soit d'initiative par partager ou qu'il
soit par une décision du Président de la
République pour faire appel au peuple
souvent d'ailleurs pour contourner le
Parlement quand le Parlement est
contourné il en est fort Marie mais
l'Assemblée nationale peut le supporter
car généralement il s'y trouve une
majorité pour soutenir l'initiative du
Président de la République quant au
Sénat lui il est mis dans une difficulté
beaucoup plus grande et il faut donc
dans notre assemblée être encore plus
attentif que dans l'autre à
l'utilisation du
référendum la délibération parlementaire
c'est la démocratie en
couleur toutes les nuances sont
représentées dans le débat et les textes
qui rentrent au Parlement en sorte
modifié enrichi par le débat
parlementaire le référendum c'est la
démocratie en noir et blanc c'est utile
pour les questions
binaires l'indépendance de l'Algérie ça
oui c'est une question qui peut être
tranchée par référendum mais ça y est ça
a été fait depuis longtemps déjà il faut
rechercher pour le référendum des
conditions précise moi j'ai une petite
préférence comme parlementaire et en
particulier comme sénateur pour la
démocratie en couleur mais si vous
préférez la démocratie en noir et blanc
à vous de le dire
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
[Applaudissements]
querouche monsieur le rapporteur je
crois qu'il faut euh il faut s'abstenir
de telle de Tell simplification dire que
quand on s'adresse au constituant c'est
la démocratie en noir et blanc c'est
faire une erreur pensez que seule la
représentation nationale peut
représenter la démocratie en couleur
c'est aussi un problème
parce que c'est aussi confisqué la voix
du constituant sur lequel se fonde
l'Ensemble de notre démocratie et
considérer encore une fois que une
partie de la population ne serait pas
qualifiée ou assez intelligente pour
répondre à des questions je pense qu'il
faut faire très attention à ce genre de
propos parce que c'est justement avec
ceci qu'on se met à l'écart de la
participation citoyenne en se mettant
au-dessus de celle-ci et représente
c'est incarner pendant un moment c'est
ne pas être au-dessus c'est être choisi
par des autres pour un moment et faire
office de ce n'est pas encore une fois
être ailleurs ça c'est le premier point
le deuxème point s'agissant de des
questions de de seuil d'une part l'idée
est de facilité et d'autre part je pense
qu'il ne faut jamais le perdre de vue la
perspective c'est d'initier la démarche
mais il ne s'agit pas du vote il s'agit
de la possibilité d'initier une démarche
avec 93 parlementaires et 1 millions de
citoyens mais encore après faut-il avoir
l'ensemble de la démarche et arriver
ensuite au référendum donc en fait il y
a deux préfiltre et il ne faut pas
considérer que ce seuil serait un seuil
décisionnel c'est un seuil de
qualification c'est complètement
différent donc dire que ce seuil est
trop bas non c'est un seuil qui permet
de faire ce qu' n'a pas été possible de
réaliser entre-temps et je finirai par
un point pour vous le référendum je vous
l'ai dit c'est la c'est c'est peut-être
la l'idée d'avoir une délibération en
noir et blanc pour moi c'est une
délibération en trois dimensions parce
que justement on prend la mesure de la
volonté du constituant à un moment donné
et c'est ça qui est important penser que
l'on peut agir sans le peuple c'est
condamner aussi la démocratie merci
Madame rossignol
[Applaudissements]
moi je vais être très rapide parce que
en fait je seraai prête à me reconnaître
totalement dans l'intervention du
président B il un instant mais il
faudrait en tirer toutes les
conséquences de ces interventions il y a
que deux options en fait dans la
sincérité que nous donons au peuple
français soit Nous abrogeons ce
référendum d'initiative partagé dans les
conditions dans lesquelles il est prévu
dans la Constitution parce que nous
considérons que en fait c'est un c'est
un couteau sans manche c'est une
illusion qui a été offerte au peuple
français dont il ne peut pas servir
qu'il ne peut pas utiliser et
l'honnêteté voudrait que nous
l'abrogions soit nous votons la
proposition qui est déposée aujourd'hui
par notre collègue chanrel et le groupe
socialiste mais par ailleurs je voulais
dire au président bas que je vais dès
demain matin reprendre le Journal
Officiel son intervention et que mot
pour mot mot pour mot nous pourrons nous
en servir lorsque vous viendrez débattre
ici l'immigration vous avez pris un
exemple en fait vous aimez les
référendum avec des questions simples
auxquelles on répond par oui ou par non
vous avez fait
le et capital pour la vie en notre pays
mais ça notre collègue à l'instant Kouge
vient d'assez bien le dire ce qui est
capit pourir d' notre pays la modestie
nous impose de penser que le peuple
aussi peut savoir ce qui est capital
pour son avenir mais votre groupe a
choisi d'ouvrir un débat au mois de
décembre sur le référendum sur
l'immigration qui peut croire
sérieusement que la question de
l'immigration est une question à
laquelle n pouvons répondre par oui ou
par non qui peut croire cela donc je
crois que vous serez dans une position
au moment du débat sur l'immigration
peut-être identique à celle
d'aujourd'hui en tout cas cas moi je
serai sur la
vôtre merci mes chers collègues je mets
au voix l'article unique constitué en
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à faciliter le
déclenchement du référendum d'initiative
partagé en application de l'article 59
du règlement le scrutin public est de
droit il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement le scrutin est
ouvert
personne demande à
voter le scrutin est
clos résultat du scrutin votant 344
exprimé 326
pour l'adoption de ce texte 102 contre
224 il n'est pas adopté mes chers
collègues je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 22h pour la lecture
des conclusions de la CMP sur le projet
de loi de finances de fin de gestion
pour 2023 la séance est
suspendue